les policiers ont d'abord n'ont pas fait
un simple contrôle de masques mais ils
sont aperçus que cet individu qui était
dans la rue avait une énorme sacoche
avec une odeur de stupéfiants très très
forte
donc c'est pour ça que cet individu
s'est réfugiée chez lui très très vite
et ensuite ils ont essayé de le
maîtriser lui-même a frappé les
policiers
un des policiers et blessé et c'est
quelqu'un qui est peut-être victime et
ça c'est l'en quête qui le dira mais en
tout état de cause c'est quelqu'un qui
est connu pour vols à main armée
association de malfaiteurs et qui a déjà
fait la prison et qui a des antécédents
judiciaires très lourd donc attendons de
voir comment se dérouleront des
investigations alors ça c'est pénible ce
qu'il vient de dire c'est très pénible
franchement et dieu sait que je suis
vraiment moi j'aime la police je la
respecte et c'est normal de la respecter
hélas si bien dire c'est minable parce
que moi j'ai rencontré ce monsieur grâce
à vous si je suis venu ici d'un
processeur michel extrêmement honnête
extrêmement sympathique extrêmement
gentil extrêmement doux et peut-être il
a quelques antécédents mais d'abord
importe c'est fini il a dit et la vie le
mec est un mec super honnête et moi
vraiment je crois en lui et là je crois
pas ce monsieur flics je suis désolé il
ya des bâtards partout et il y avait
trois bâtard les trois flics là bas ils
vont payer sont révoqués c'est bien fait
pour leur gueule et méchant faut pas
jeter l'opprobre sur toute la profession
parce que 95 ailleurs mais chez les
flics sont formidables parce qu'elle a
dit michel qu'est ce qu'a dit michel
ancien patron du raid
bien sûr pour nos pauvres marraine sur
cette affaire qui a pris une ampleur
incroyable et on le comprend
même le président de la république
emmanuel macron a réagi là dessus on
avait vu votre mise de tutelle gérald
darmanin qui était au au jt de france 2
qui avait réagi aussi le soir même
quel est votre action là dessus vous
parce que c'est ça que maintenant vous
êtes rattaché au ministère de
l'intérieur
moi j'ai été très choquée par les faits
et je trouve je crois qui a rien qui
excusent qu'on se mettent à plusieurs
pour tabasser un homme quel que soit
la raison ou l'historique d'ailleurs et
moi je voudrais dire surtout que j'ai
regardé le passage de michèle pardon de
la paix par la famille chagnon lui
manquer de respect mais voilà ce
monsieur qui était là et moi j'ai trouvé
que ce monsieur il était très sage dans
ses paroles parce qu'il a vécu d une
agression traumatisante
jean gadrey traumatisante eu égard aux
blessures dont souffre et il a dit
justement je veux pas jeter l'opprobre
sur toute la police
je vois que ces personnes rendent compte
et je veux justice mais je veux pas
appelé à la violence en mon nom je
demande aux gens de ne pas commettre de
violences
et je crois qu'on est dans un dans un
dans une société on a trop peur les uns
des autres on a certains jeunes qui me
disent qu'ils ont peur quand je croise
la police on a des policiers qui ont
peur parce qu'ils sont menacés parce
qu'ils sont policiers parfois menacés de
mort jusque chez eux
moi je crois que notre travail à tous
quand on a la chance d'avoir accès à la
parole publique quelle que soit notre
rôle c'est vraiment justement de
déconstruire ses peurs et de faire que
les gens se parlent et je crois que ce
monsieur michel il a eu vraiment un rôle
positif en disant qu'ils disaient non à
toute forme de violence et ça ça doit
être salué